for you
becoming a gm i mean assistant gm at
first with
jerry west for those seven years which
jerry west to me he's just a
qualified genius who is who he is when
the when the lakers lost him
there's a couple people when the lakers
lost that i was concerned one of them
was him
the other one was cup check i don't know
why i kind of like cupcake style and i
also like
jerry style what was it like working
with jerry for those seven years at
memphis grizzlies
yeah the the the path in was through
vancouver
right we bought the vancouver grizzlies
and then we moved him to memphis so
there were two years without jerry and
then
five with jerry jerry then came into
memphis as the
president of basketball and
it was amazing i mean at that time
patrick that was you play that game
where you're like who would you want to
have lunch with if there was anybody you
could have lunch with and people
say oprah or you know lately you'd say
obama whatever it would be
in my window there my answer was jerry
west because i wanted to
learn something that was relevant to
what i wanted well all of a sudden he
was
his office was like four feet from mine
and his door is always open and he was
an open book right he just would
would uh allow and ask for help and we
worked very closely together with it
with a team of people and it was just
unbelievable quite the experience
and uh you know a lot of fun to work
with
um he had true
stardust sprinkled on him still at that
age he
he you know did what was interesting
with jerry was to see
grown men in their 60s just like
fan girl out on him when they'd see him
at a restaurant
because they had seen him for you know
40 or 50 years they had this familiarity
with him as he
you know he's one of those rare athletes
that transformed himself
into being just as successful in the
second
phase in a different way right so i
never knew him as a player i just knew
him as this iconic executive sort of
what you're reacting to
but jerry uh was a is a special person
you know
totally unique and was a lot of fun
working with him what was his recruiting
style i mean there's different ways guys
recruit i i've kind of
watched him closely to see how he
recruited i watched how cupchick
recruited dwight howard he brought him
in took him in one of the rooms he says
look at the rafters look who's up there
the big man
kareem will shack one day it's going to
say howard there and then
you know you kind of saw that didn't
work out with howard's personality
because he didn't want that kind of
pressure to be compared to the shadows
of the guys what was jerry's style of
recruiting
well we were recruiting a different
caliber of athlete we were doing a build
from you know one of the worst teams in
the league so in a way it was drafting
talent and then retaining talent and
then
getting guys on the just getting talent
at any level but it wasn't
those kinds of superstars where you're
recruiting it was more
let's get this guy to come let's
identify let's trade for him
a lot of those conversations happen very
directly with agents
so that was where it was a you know i
mentioned arntellum
as an example so aaron was a very close
friend of jerry's
arn representing kobe bryant and a
number of the other
key acquisitions through the years for
the lakers
and they were i was surprised at just
how close they were
uh personally you know i always envision
that that'd be more of a
contentious relationship and yeah we
hate agents and this and that but what
you learned what i learned from jerry
was just the importance of deep
long-standing relationships with the
power agents because so many of those
guys control so much of the talent and
they can really help
fulfill what you're trying to accomplish
so that was part of the art part of the
science of what you'd call recruiting or
talent procurement
in the nba so he was a relationship
salesman
so he sold through having strong
relationships with agents because
if he got the agents he got the player
so it's half the battle of recruiting
players
and having a good relationship with
players through
the agent how much of it is the agent
how much of it is the family how much of
it is the wife how much of it is the
parents how much of it is the player
or does it vary player by player well
it's changed
um it was a little more agent driven
back then
and in the modern era i think it's a
little more peer
and player to player driven so you see
more and more the way that
lebron is a player combined with
maverick carter and his agency that
lebron is an owner of they're able to
assemble the current lakers roster in a
way where they're doing a lot of the
maneuvering and manipulating
and the straight-up recruiting you know
the
the straight-up recruiting is
technically illegal if it comes from
any member of an other team that's
tampering you can't tamper with
current players on other rosters well
a loophole in that has been player to
player where the players
we can't restrict what they do or say to
each other so
over the last 10 years or so that's
really taken form
you know even going back to pat riley
was the last one in miami to really
assemble the big three down there with a
true recruiting focus he went in and
sold him and pitched him he had weighed
but he had to get wade to recommit
and then he got lebron and bosh to join
but the the other secret of that success
was he got them all to take like 5
million less than they should have taken
18 million 19 million 16 million i don't
remember the number and i think
even bosch was getting the most money
out of the three right so they all took
a haircut of 5 million that freed up 15
million a year to go get
the next three you know the mike millers
of the world the way they all murders
roster out and really gave them the
the finals championship caliber every
year so
um but now it's much more you know james
harden
goes to be with durant and goes to be
with kyrie because there's direct
conversations happening as part of that
whole exchange
uh you know when chris paul moves or
maneuvers he's
talking direct with whoever he's going
to be playing with and of course
lebron bringing anthony davis
represented by that same group you know
that was the core
the key to transitioning the lakers from
worst to first
so if you like this sort of short clip
from an interview i did click over here
to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel take care
everybody bye